the path the warpath path of war moving  toward a battle fight towards the actual  war against our nation's enemies or the  war against my own weaknesses preparing  and and sharpening my sword and honing  my skills and maintaining the  unmitigated daily discipline in all  things where does it lead it can be  in fact I am waiting in a because the  warpath is a war against weakness and so  it needs to sway its  war against ignorance and so it needs to  polish  delivers others need  the warpath needs to control and leads  to ownership of your life  and that is the warpath  fired in adversity the path of blood and  of sweat and of suffering  is  a path of discipline which is why  it means the food and beyond that in the  end  it beats  [Music]